this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm george campbell host of the
fine print and entree leadership podcast
joined today by none other than rachel
cruz best-selling author and all-around
great person rachel so good to be with
you thank you you know what john dolonie
says when i host him all around great
human beings it's true
i'll take whatever i can get i try to
well ken likes to say colleague and that
feels a little old-timey to me
so i'd rather say friend great person
she's a she's a mother king coleman is
like a you know like a solid 85 year old
he's an older in the heart i know yeah
but we're fat we're pals yeah oh he
loves to say powell my pal
well rachel this is a first milestone
day first time that we have co-hosted
the ramsay show i know george it's a
distinct honor when i saw it on the
schedule i thought yes me and george you
were legitimately excited i was okay
that makes me feel because you're
because you're great george you're yeah
and you're you're driving you're doing
the whole thing i'm doing it i'm excited
no no training wheels
i know so
it's great it's great you've had a big a
big couple weeks number one you went to
disney i did and i don't know if you
loved it more than the kids did oh man
it's just it is the happiest place on
earth people will will argue that
but i'll say what made it so fun is our
girls we left baby charles at home so we
took we took the six-year-old and the
four-year-old the four-year-old was just
that 40 inches if you know anything
about disney world you you gotta hit
that 40 inch mark and then you can do
most everything most everything
anyways they were just game on i mean
they did every roller coaster they did
tower terror they i mean they loved it
and little caroline the tower of terror
oh we got down and she was like mom
towel a toe is so crazy my stomach was
all the way up and she like pointed to
her throat i was like i know isn't it
the craziest feeling that's amazing
that's a problem fireworks you know
there's something about there's
something about being there even as an
adult like i mean i tear up at the
fireworks because the song that plays
and all the old movies are flashed on
the castle you know they do this crazy
projection and it makes you feel like
you can do anything child like wonder
and joy makes you feel like anything is
possible anything i can chase my dreams
anything is possible rachel you're
living the dream this is so great that's
how i felt george but thanks for
bringing that up i just i knew it'd
light you up and i wanted to start off
the show on a good note here so it's a
free call this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two
five two two five i almost threw like 11
numbers in there for fun triple a eight
two five five two two five rachel and i
would be happy to take your call about
pretty much anything i mean we'll give
it a shot you know whatever you're going
through sometimes people call and they
just need some affirmation they go i
think i know that this is the answer but
or i know what to do but i just can't
bring myself to do it that's right
absolutely well and it's about
everything and that's what i love i love
the format of this show because i love
diving into people's
stories and problems or celebrations all
of it and we kind of get just a
four-minute little
little uh insert into their life and so
we just want to talk yeah and hang out
and and ask good questions hopefully to
you the listener to get you to think and
give you know some
some guidance on what we've experienced
over yeah a few decades of doing this oh
yeah not your first rodeo rachel well
i'm excited let's do it let's go to the
phones tyler is in tallahassee
tyler welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are you guys doing great how can
we help
hey so i have a
kind of a conundrum right now in my life
i work full time as like a maintenance
guy and um i'm also i own my own
business i have a small blueberry farm
and um my farm is almost to the size
where i can
say you know what let's just forget
maintenance we're going to do farming
full-time but it's nice to have two
incomes right now and i'm kind of like
torn as to what i should do but i've at
where i'm currently located like in my
job i'm as high as i can possibly get
like i cannot make any more like there's
nowhere else for me to go i'm already as
high as you know i'm going to be paid
for basically the rest of my career here
and so i'm kind of like on the sense of
whether i should make you know make the
big jump in to you know own my own
business and become my own
you know boss or stay where i'm at and
i'm only 26 years old so i'm kind of
like
the 26 year olds are not supposed to be
making these decisions right now
yes you are you're doing it you're
crushing them tyler you're killing it
okay so my question is i think i know
the answer but i'm going to just ask
what do you want to do full time do you
want to be in maintenance full-time or
do you want to do the farm full-time
oh i wouldn't love the farm full-time i
just i love it yeah so what do you make
at your full-time job in maintenance um
around 41
and that's the max that you'll ever make
yeah we get like a three percent raise
every year but that's just cost of
living so but yeah i'm as high as i'll
ever make okay and what's the farm
bringing in right now
um so this year was our first actual
crop we made we probably netted about
40.
um next year we're going to net around
60 and that's just you know this is only
like 10 acres so and i have a lot more
land that i could expand on if i didn't
have you know
40 hours a week that i was working as a
maintenance guy you know
yep well tyler whenever we talk to
people that have kind of the side thing
that they love and it gets built up to a
point to transition full-time um you
know dave always says that it's not like
this leap of faith and just picture like
a boat and a dock and we don't want you
stepping off the dock into water you
want the boat close enough that maybe it
feels a little uncomfortable it's a
little bit of a stretch but you can
still get on and these numbers tyler
like if you were saying i'm making 15
grand at the blueberry farm and i think
i want to jump into that i'd be like
let's give it a little bit but you've
proven it and obviously proven a level
of of business because you're going to
be growing next year
and and so yeah i mean if it's
comparable to what you're making now
that that's kind of the perfect
situation tyler and you said that you're
gonna miss this this extra money from
having two incomes where are you guys at
financially are you out of debt
completely do you have an emergency fund
well we do have emergency fund and
that's part of like it's taken us a lot
of money to get to where we are
um we owe a little on our house still
probably like a hundred thousand
um we i just bought a truck that i
basically had to
um we got it used but we still owe like
i think 20 000 on it and then the farm
has its own you know debt we we did it
with like a llc to you know completely
separate
to where if something was to happen to
the farm business we would never you
know we were not putting our house up
against anything so we wouldn't lose our
house so you've got farm debt plus the
truck other than your your primary
residence
your mortgage yes okay a little bit
probably like 30 grand left on the farm
but my hope is next year to pay that off
using some of that extra so i'm not
it's kind of a twofold deal because i'm
i'm like maxed out on my
my physical strengths right now like i
cannot you know i can't expand
you know
off of working 40 hours a week full time
as a maintenance man also you know what
i mean well i i think part of the every
night on my blueberry farm yeah i bet
you're hustling man i'm proud of you i
think what you need to do here you got
to get out of debt we got to get rid of
the truck loan we got to get rid of this
farm debt so that when you go down to
one income you're not freaking out
there's not anxiety around it you don't
have your budget's not too tight that's
what's going to set you up for success
so i if i'm you i'm keeping this
full-time job until i can get out of
debt and as soon as i'm out of debt and
this farm is bringing in some steady
income i'm going to take that nice
little walk off the dock that's right no
that's a great point george because
again setting yourself up well having
two incomes right now you're going to be
able to grow this farm it doesn't have
to be tomorrow it can be in six to eight
months once you pay off the truck yeah
and the blueberry farm that just sounds
like a nice life rachel if i could just
jump today i'd probably a little start a
little blueberry blueberries i do that's
great sounds awesome way to go man hey
this is the ramsay show give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
four
three
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by
ramsey personality best-selling author
host of the rachel cruz show you guessed
it rachel cruz this is awesome rachel
it's been a big uh big week for you
your wallet uh is one of my favorites
and here's the here's the thing i'm
biased towards the color camel for
obvious reasons but you released a new
color this week that's very exciting yes
what is it release it to the world i
don't know oh guys i'm so excited about
this so it's
by popular demand this is the one color
that people were asking for so we were
like okay we hear you and we will
deliver but it's called classic brown
nice medium i know
so this is really i think one of the
perfect a perfect gift for people i
wanted it before all the holiday
craziness happens i was like i want to
get it out before because if you have a
lady in your life if you are a woman and
you're like you know what i want to make
budgeting just beautiful and fun and
stylish there's a lot of ugly wallets
out there especially and here's the
thing we we preach the envelope system
that's right and you have built-in slots
which is incredible that's right for
each category yes so with this yes there
are four slots for your cash
specifically and lots of debit card and
card space for membership cards debit
cards i know i know but it's um it's
great because we partnered with join
which is an incredible organization in
india and they employ people out of
really just hardship um there in that
country and teach them a skill and a
trade and they're the ones that that
truly make these and each wallet too i
love that you get a card with the person
who made it that's so cool so you get
their signature but uh it's authentic
handmade
really really great quality i mean it
probably smells amazing i know it does i
mean it's you can smell that so on the
right you guys yes so
again if you want to get this for a lady
in your life if you are a lady and
you're like um i want this for christmas
so make sure
that you're getting your husbands your
man and say hey here's an easy gift here
it is yep so it's availa available to
order now we'll ship in early november
and so you can text rc brown to 33789
to get all the information here on the
new
classic brown wallet i love it we had
the founder of join come speak at a
devotional for our team she was
absolutely absolutely incredible and
hearing the stories and the impact and
how passionate she is about this uh it
just made me happy that's what i love to
partner with yes and there are
incredible organizations out there in
the world that's kind of what i don't
know i just i love i feel like it's more
than ever it seems like but uh join is
definitely one of those that you're like
okay when i purchase something like this
like obviously it's gonna help me with
my budget my money everything we talk
about cashing out certain categories in
your budget
helping you stay on track but literally
these per this purchase helps someone on
the other side of the world and it's uh
i don't know there's something powerful
about that yeah absolutely well
congratulations on that open phone lines
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five jamie joins us in
philadelphia pennsylvania jamie welcome
to the ramsay show
what's going on guys hey how can we help
so i've been listening to you guys for
the past couple weeks but um i've yet to
read and like look into the steps for
financial peace i guess um i'm 19 years
old and i plan on buying my first duplex
pretty soon but i'm going to be
purchasing with the mortgage
um i plan on like i've been hearing from
a lot of you guys to stay out of like
that but i also heard from other sources
to stay out of bad debt
so i was just curious like what is the
difference
of like
that didn't get that i guess i mean i
plan on renting out both sides of
duplexes so i'm gonna have some cash
flow on top of it but
yeah i'm just pretty much curious um
so i guess that's pretty much yeah so
jamie i'll say what the world says what
the culture is saying when they're
saying quote unquote good debts
it's usually in purposes of an
investment you know people say well
student loans are good debt because it's
an investment in yourself
they'll talk about a mortgage being good
debt or if you're taking data on your
business because you're gonna make money
so like that's the way the world kind of
operates when it comes to the system but
here at ramsey
uh i'll just tell you we're pretty weird
and so we say
all debts all debt
is bad debt now a mortgage i'll say this
with the asterisk a mortgage is the one
type of debts that we will not yell at
you for on your primary mortgage so
other than that though and the reason
why jamie is because
one of your largest wealth building tool
tools out there is your income and for a
lot of people
78 of americans are living paycheck to
paycheck and the money comes in their
income does and it's going out on
average 500 something dollars to car to
a car payment they're paying their
student loans average family has 16 000
of credit card debt i mean like their
income is leaving so there is no margin
in their life to do things like giving
investing saving even spending on what
they want
in order to do those things they have to
go deeper in debt right so it's like the
cycle that ends up playing and then what
we have found too is over the course of
time that cycle just wears on you
emotionally spiritually
financially you're just not able to seem
to get traction and so
the idea of avoiding debt
completely
gives you power it gives you control it
gives you choices when you don't owe
anyone anything and you want to quit
your job and move to another job you can
because you don't have bills like there
there is something powerful when you
don't owe money to anyone
um that would be my take and george you
yeah yeah well jamie the thing is the
people who tell you there is such thing
at good debt they don't pay your bills
you do and so when it comes down to debt
it really is stealing from your income
and so i know you want to get into this
duplex and you're 19. i mean that's
that's very impressive yeah it is
absolutely and i think it's awesome that
you want to do this but i i would
challenge you to go against the grain
when it comes to pretty much anything
society says uh so when it comes to good
debt versus bad debt yes we do believe
that all debt is bad because it steals
from your income that you that you work
really hard for do you have any debt
right now
um i mean i went to trade school um and
i ended up paying like it was like 25
000 total so yeah i do have debt but i
make 80k a year so it's like wow what do
you do i'm curious it was an investment
um
it's hvac so heating ventilation air
conditioning
but wow i mean
that's why i didn't look at it as like
too terrible and that's why i'm calling
you today because exactly like if you
guys think that like investments like if
you're buying a mortgage to like maybe
make some more money you know and it's
not necessarily a bad thing like say i
get the house for under market value and
it's worth more than i've paid like
that's what i was pretty much curious
about obviously you guys helped me out a
lot yeah i appreciate it thank you no
absolutely and i'll just kind of tack on
to that jamie too that you know when it
comes to
people try to play the math game so much
when it comes to life and money right
and so that idea hey i'm gonna you know
people say well i'm gonna borrow on my
on my mortgage because i can actually to
put that money in the market and borrow
against my house because the math works
i can make more in investing or i'm not
gonna pay off my mortgage because you
know i mean like there's there's a math
games that we can play all day but one
thing jamie just to just to note that
people do not um
take life and risk into consideration
people don't take in 2008 when the
market completely crashed at the housing
market and people that had these
mortgages that thought they were okay
went into foreclosure people didn't
factor in a recession where entire
industries were out of work i mean there
are things that happen in life so the
the le when you don't have debt even a
mortgage but when you don't have debt
you don't have risk
and there is something about that that
is that is huge in the end you know and
even the student loan
um id and i know you went to trade
school you said and you took out money
and it was an investment you and all
that you know which which is great i
want to shame you for any of that but
also pushing people to think differently
to know that i can actually go get an
education i can actually go to trade
school
and and do things that i don't have to
take out debt so we really do here at
ramsey we we push against these messages
because what we have found time and time
again
is that people live with this debt and
it eats into their income and then it
eventually is this thief that it steals
your steals your peace of mind it steals
your sleep
and again there is something powerful
when you don't owe anyone anything yeah
rachel and we talk about this all the
time but the quickest way to building
wealth is to get back your greatest
wealth building tool which is your
income and so jamie i think it's awesome
you want to get this duplex but you're
telling me how you have this debt and
you're wanting to get into this
investment property or your primary
residence so i would challenge you with
this amazing income you have pay off all
of your debt first
get a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses if you
don't already have that if you do have
some money sitting around attack the
student loan debt first that's baby step
two i know you've been listening just
for a few weeks now baby step three
you're gonna get that emergency fund in
place and then we call it three b is
where you save up for that down payment
on that house and we want you to do that
on a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage with a
payment that's no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay so a lot of numbers
there but all of this is so that you can
win with money so you don't have this
anxiety and burden in your life when
you're trying to do too many things at
once so that's the way to do it man
you're 19 you're making a great income
and shout out to the trades man 80k
you're 19 years old because you want to
trade school amazing way to go this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to feartalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
three
[Music]
so
[Music]
i am george campbell ramsey personality
joined today by ramsey personality
rachel cruz and on the debt-free stage
in the lobby of ramsey solutions we've
got jason and katie how you guys doing
hey good how are you you excited to be
here we are so excited you guys are just
a cute couple i'm excited i'm pumped for
this story where are you guys from
we are for i'm originally from georgia
valdosta georgia and katie's from
hattiesburg and that's where we met
very nice okay so so how much have you
paid off uh 130 000
in 22 months oh my gosh whoa okay and
what was the range of income during this
time uh i started out at 110
and then from there i moved we moved up
to around 155.
where we're at now okay so whose debt
was this all mine
ah
student loans all student loans
so was katie on this journey was this
kind of a solo journey and she came
along it was it started on a solo
journey and she came along after that we
got married back in july we met two
years ago
um before that and everything so
newlyweds everyone listening cannot see
you obviously people on youtube right
now because you guys are you look young
can i ask how old you are i'm
twenty-seven
twenty-two twenty-seven twenty-two so
you are debt-free
at 27 years old yes ma'am what kind of
debt was this so this was all student
loan debt from my grad school really ten
thousand of it was undergrad but the
other 120 000
was from cardiovascular perfusion school
wow so i went to nebraska and uh
perfusion school is not cheap
um it sounds expensive i just learned
that word and it just feels like an
expensive word six six six numbers i owe
you money every time i say it
so what is that so um basically it's a
small field not a lot of people know
about we operate the heart lung machine
during heart surgery keep the blood
flowing you know we're basically the
heart and lungs for a patient whenever
we go on bypass
we're essentially the bypass you know
for them and it's a small field it's
less than uh 4 000 perfusionist in the
in the united states total so that's
what you do full time obviously because
you're making a great income yes ma'am
and katie what do you do i'm in grad
school for accounting awesome wonderful
smart people here on this stage and
katie went to school debt-free
completely and now she's got a ga
position which pays for her school too
which is
awesome so you're going grad school
debt-free too i assume so because you
guys are on that first stage together so
that's amazing katie well done thank you
this is amazing so 22 months ago you
were sitting there with 130 000 in debt
most people just go i'll pay it off when
i die right what made you get on this
journey 22 months ago so it was really
four years ago i started listening to
dave ramsey and stuff like that and
whenever i was in perfusion school i
started out i was in minnesota you know
on a rotation there because after our
first year we have to go on rotations
and when i was in minnesota i was
mountain biking one afternoon and i just
was i loved to do anything outdoors and
you know after a long day at work that's
what i was doing and i was just like
i've got so much debt and i've got to
get a plan figure it out for something
so for that entire year every morning
when i was going to any of my rotation
sites i would listen to the dave ramsey
show i listened to the podcast and i was
hearing all these people talk about
their debt-free screams how they paid x
amount of income they had whatever job
and they were doing it and it was it was
a little bit of debt and some people was
a ton of debt and it was just like i
know i can do this too and so
my motive was you know right after i
graduated you know a ton of people in my
class you know or not a ton of people
but a few people they went out and
bought houses they went out and bought
new cars some of them went and bought
pets like all these all these things
that add up you know nothing wrong pets
i'm just dogs are expensive sometimes
but anyways so
so a lot of people went and bought a lot
of stuff and i was just like i don't
want to be one of those people i want to
be one of these weird people you know so
basically what happened was i took this
job in hattiesburg it was a good income
and mississippi is pretty cheap to live
at
um and so you know with that i was just
like i've got a i've got to figure out a
plan and so my plan was you know in
total money makeover dave talks about
you know pay off your smallest debt to
your largest debts and i had my
undergrad loans which were 10 000 you
know so i paid those off in the first
two months i started working and then
after that i had four
loans that were 20 000 a piece and i
just started chunking away at each one
of them one at a time you know paying
off i pay off 20 000 and then be oh this
is exciting let's do another 20 000. and
i just kept it rolling every month i
paid a minimum of 5 000 on these loans
and i had my checks split where 25 of it
would go on my bank account that i used
and the other 75 percent i knew it was
just going to go straight to the debt
straight to the debt every month so i
wouldn't get like sidetracked with that
and so then the biggest one was like 37
000 you know from perfusion school and
that was the last one and that one was
the most difficult you know really but
what i would say what really
you know helped a lot those first six
months were extremely difficult you know
because everybody else was buying stuff
i wanted to play golf all the time i
wanted a golf membership i wanted to
join the country club all this stuff and
i was just like i can't do that right
now maybe afterwards but not right now
and so
um there's two things that really kick
started after those six months that made
me like okay i'm kind of seeing a lot in
the tunnel you know um covet happened
and you know that was really bad for a
lot of people a lot of businesses um and
i hate that for everybody but really for
me that was one of the best things
because you know everything was shut
down i felt like i wasn't missing out on
anything
we were cooking in a lot you know i'd go
see katie up in starkville we'd eat in
you know she'd come to hattiesburg and
we'd eat in you know we couldn't go out
to eat and so that was a lot of what we
did and we couldn't go to concerts
couldn't get a football game nothing
like that and so it made it a lot easier
and
you know the president put the student
loans at zero percent you know so i told
myself i know i've got to put 6 000 away
every month it was a little more
difficult but i just made sure it
happened and then we started talking
about marriage you know and so i told
katie before we got married i was going
to be debt-free and have six months of
my emergency expenses saved up and we
did it yeah wow and she was a great
supporter do you just were you just so
attracted to him were you like man this
guy is absolutely gonna take care of all
these situations literally there are so
many so many couples that they are not
on the same page and and we talked to or
i talked to a lot of women and they just
are begging for their husband to get on
board like i just want my husband on
board and man yeah it was awesome we had
to think of like a lot of things to do
without spending money when we were dead
because we started dating us like right
when you graduated yeah he was paying
off his loans and so we would go do a
lot of outdoor things and cook in like
he said you would like you were broke so
that later you could live like you're
not broke that's right it's the best we
would we did a lot of like you know up
in starkville we'd go hiking we'd drive
to north alabama go hiking i mean
hiking's free doesn't cost anything so
that's that's a lot of what we did now
it's one of our favorite hobbies that's
incredible man so any other cheerleaders
in the story obviously katie was
probably the biggest yeah katie was
definitely the biggest um my family was
definitely supportive of me as well and
her family
also a lot of people thought i was crazy
like trying to pay off all this debt
they just looked at me like there's no
way you'll do that like good luck but
that's not going to happen and i was
like if i set a goal i'm going to
accomplish
jason man don't get in his way that's
impressive but even the things you set
up jason like having 75 of your paycheck
going to right like having all this this
even manual so you can't get in the way
right like i'm going to put things in
place to protect me from myself right
absolutely but it is it's impressive and
you i mean you did it in less than two
years yeah and there there is something
and even the student loan thing when it
went to zero percent like you took
advantage a lot of people took their
foot off the gas and said awesome i get
to just coast and instead you did such a
smart move of stepping on that
yes absolutely and another thing too
that i failed to mention was you know at
my clinic that i work for and all so we
get access to the doctor's lounge and
they include and everybody's gonna laugh
when i say this but they include um like
free meals for us for lunch you know
every day and so what i would do is i
would eat half of my lunch at work take
the other half home and eat it for
dinner and people would like say all
kinds of things they laugh at me thought
it was the dumbest thing and i said i'm
trying to get debt free this is free
this is part of my salary so i this is
what i do now that's right sometimes we
would share it he's like bring it home
and we share it for dinner this is
lovely it brings it brings them together
let's get to it guys we've got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that's the
next step in your very young lives and a
copy of the total money makeover for you
to pay it forward to maybe another young
couple who's starting out their life
with student loan debt so let's get to
it jason and katie from hattiesburg
mississippi 130 thousand dollars paid
off in 22 months making 110 up to 155k
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
there it is look at the smiles on those
faces right now i love it that's as good
as disney world in my book that oh it is
well that's that's a life-changing i
love seeing young couples start off
their their married lives on a good foot
good foot this is it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
four
three
[Music]
i'm george campbell host of the fine
print and entree leadership podcast
joined today by none other than rachel
cruz you know rachel we just heard a
great debt free scream about paying off
130 000
in student loan debt and this is an
absolute crisis you've dug into it a lot
i've dug into it a lot and if you're not
strapped with student loan payments the
odds are you know someone who is someone
that you love family members friends
millions of people are putting their
lives on hold they can't buy a house or
have kids because they feel stuck or
even worse they're waiting and waiting
and waiting for the government to save
them with student loan forgiveness what
a joke so our team has produced a brand
new feature film documentary called
borrowed future and it is finally out it
uncovers the dark side of the student
loan industry and exposes how the system
is built to work against you you'll see
dave ramsey weigh in on the epic failure
otherwise known as the student loan
program along with featured interviews
from industry insiders and thought
leaders like seth goad and seth fratman
and dr john deloney we are coming at
this issue hard folks we're taking big
swings at the student loan industry with
the goal to arm parents and students
across the country with this
mind-blowing truth you do not have to
take out loans to get a college
education you can be a student without a
student loan and you can graduate debt
free and avoid the predatory student
loan industry so go watch this thing
bard future is available to watch now on
apple tv amazon prime video google play
or at borrowed future dot com we are
taking your calls this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
happy to answer them and carla is in san
antonio carlo welcome to the ramsey show
hi guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we help today
okay um so my spouse and i were
currently wrapping up on baby step three
will be done at the end of the month and
as we start preparing for the 15
into retirement i have a question about
volatile income so
there we have some side hustle income
and my spouse is a new uh real estate
agent so i was wondering is it okay if i
take
my fixed salary and save 15 of that and
then take
the side hustle money and throw it at
the mortgage
or how do i just or i guess like how do
i balance that into the 15 i guess is my
question
okay so you've got you have your
full-time job and you have some side
hustle income and you're saying hey can
i invest just my full-time job and not
the side hustle income
right because it's so volatile yeah
exactly yeah that's a great question uh
we we tell people to invest 15 of their
household income that means any money
coming in that year so if i'm you i'm
taking 15 of the side hustle income and
i assume you're still going to have
margin left over because you're
debt-free with an emergency fund to
still put that money towards your next
step towards the house
is that right yeah
well kind of yes and no um i just i was
thinking
you know sometimes it's a good income
sometimes it's not a lot and so just a
little extra towards the mortgage and
like really attacking that would seem
i don't know
like a better use of uh time i guess i'm
i don't know not really sure how to
how that would work do you guys have
kids or is it just you too
no we have we have two chips we have two
kids okay so we also tell people after
the 15 to be investing for the kids
college have you guessed uh will you
guys plan on doing that after you're
investing 15
um yes that's the plan so it sounds like
you might need this income not for
paying off the house right now but to at
least make sure we've got the the kids
college taken care of first
okay
okay so i i love the i can tell that you
are very excited to pay off this house
and i'm in that stage now too in baby
step six we don't have kids so we're not
as worried about college at the moment
but what i'm telling you is to take 15
of that side hustle income and you're
still going to have 85 of that side
hustle income to put towards your other
goals and you should have margin in your
full-time jobs to put towards those
other goals so if i'm tracking with you
you've got a few steps before you're
getting to the house payoff
okay so then how do we take the 15 of
the volatile income how do we do that
month over month if it changes well
we're not really sure if like what that
looks like so do we just take another 15
off of that as well exactly the way yeah
if a thousand dollars comes in well
you're gonna take fifteen percent of the
thousand dollars if a hundred dollars
comes in you're gonna take fifteen
percent of that hundred dollars
okay so that keeps it simple and that
way you're not racking your brain each
month yes and carla you know my husband
and i because i'm on
mine and some of his is a lot of
commission based so there's some months
that is much larger than others so we'll
even true up at the end of the year um
we try you know be as consistent as we
can and then we'll look at the end of
the year to make sure hey
have we did we do the 15 and if we
didn't we and we have a money market
account to the side and we will pull
like we we make sure it's that 15 and
beyond because we're on baby step 7 but
um but making sure that that's hit
because again sometimes it is hard i
understand it's life and it's crazy and
you know month months just fly by and
sometimes you don't you're not as
diligent um
every single month so just truing up at
the end of the year too just to double
double check is something that we do as
well carla do you how much of your
take-home pay is this house the mortgage
payment right now
how much of my take-home pay is the
mortgage um i'm not sure we take our
mortgage payment is about 1800 months
and we make
at my full-time job i mean 93 a year
okay
and that's not your full household
income or is it
no so so that's my that's what we kind
of live off of but that's what we've
been doing so we live off the full-time
income and then all
the side hustle volatile income is what
we've been saving for emergency funds
and then so now what we're trying to do
is like okay how do we
i guess capitalize on the fact that we
have the room to just live off of one
income yeah um
so my 93 a year covers all of our
expenses everything and then the rest of
it we're just wondering like can we just
really take that and be aggressive
and throw it towards a mortgage but you
know i guess what i'm hearing is that we
need to take also 15 off of that and
throw it into retirement and yeah baby
step five as well yeah don't forget
about that baby step five for sure and i
the reason i ask is to make sure that
this mortgage payment isn't just like
eating up your entire income to where
you don't have that margin so you're
doing the right things we just got to
add that step in for college and that
the mortgage payment will come and and
you'll get rid of that thing in no time
with your gazelle intensity that you
guys have so i think that's awesome
andrew joins us in indianapolis
andrew welcome to the ramsay show
hey rachel and george thanks for taking
my call absolutely how can we help
yeah so just a quick question
my wife and i are on baby step three
and we've got about 5 000 in our
emergency fund
i'm in a commission based job and so a
lot of my pay gets deducted at a 22 tax
rate
which we are not anywhere close to that
so um i did some calculations and our
tax refund is going to be uh
pretty large pretty substantial and will
complete our baby step three um in march
of
22. and so i was just wondering do we
just continue
filling up that that that baby step
three even though it's like only two to
seven hundred dollars a month
um
or do we go ahead and stop and start
investing like we're in baby step four
five and six uh knowing that that
emergency fund will be complete in march
when we get our tax refund
yeah i wouldn't wait until that tax
refund comes in i mean you guys sound
like you're on this plan i would keep
saving up for that emergency fund and
when that refund does come you can use
that towards your next steps so maybe
that's a down payment on a house or
whatever that goal may be
and then obviously you're going to be
investing that 15 of your household
income into retirement once you have
that emergency fund but i don't want you
waiting till march that's like six
months from now you guys could be way
further along if you just do this thing
you're on your own yeah absolutely and
the great thing is keep chipping away at
it because when that check does come if
you guys haven't hit
your savings goals again you know that
check's coming so when it does hit and
you actually have the money then you can
say okay great here's a couple thousand
from that refund that we can put here
and then we can throw a big lump sum
maybe into an investment or like george
said if you guys are saving up for a
house so you're going to be able to use
that money
um but still i yeah i would still
because something could happen in
january and you're going to need an
emergency fund that's what it's there
for right it's there for when life
happens or not if when life happens
because it will so um that's awesome
that you know you'll be getting those
refunds um and that you will have some
cash can you not adjust the withholdings
no this is the fourth 22 percent i've
tried
yeah i've i've contacted every hr
department
i just don't like the government holding
on to your money interest fee free i
don't like that at all
you you you and me both
but all right well thank you absolutely
yeah thanks for the call appreciate that
yeah and i think you know that's it's a
great question that he asked because i
think for a lot of people whether it's a
bonus an end of the year bonus you know
is coming a tax refund you know a chunk
of money is coming
but to still be diligent in the moment
to say okay i'm still gonna work this
plan it takes intentionality but then
when the money does hit then it's great
then it's just the cherry on top i just
love when things are in your control and
you can just decide to save up for that
emergency fund instead of hoping waiting
i don't like that at all i'm impatient i
guess rachel who knows well that puts
this hour of the ramsey show in the
books my thanks to our board engineer
ben hill acting producer kelly daniel
and many other people that keep this
show afloat of course my co-host rachel
cruz and you america thanks for
listening in we'll be back with you
before you know it this is the ramsay
show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcast four
three
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm ramsay personality george
campbell host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast joined today
by the amazing rachel cruz best-selling
author her latest know yourself know
your money a smash hit some would say
some would say it's so good i love it i
love what you dug into with this stuff
because we
have largely we had a lot of the
tactical here's what to do here's the
plan yeah and in this book there's a ton
of research about these money classrooms
what are those yes so
the book dives into really why we handle
money the way we do part of that is our
upbringing right the household you grew
up in was your classroom it's where you
learned
life lessons some lessons we wish we
could probably unlearn right but some
lessons you just naturally take with you
into adulthood and money is one of those
so
there is the anxious classroom the
unstable classroom the unaware classroom
and the secure classroom so these all
have to do with how money was verbally
communicated how money was emotionally
communicated whether it was stressed or
or
peaceful i mean all of these it kind of
makes this um this quadrant if you will
so i talk about each of those classrooms
in the book and how
how the good sides of it the bad sides
of them and how to really get to this
place we're like okay i'm in a secure
money classroom which is
where you're emotionally calm and
verbally open about money in your
current nuclear family that's big and
you know we're big fans of counseling
around here and
counseling 101 you find out what
happened in the childhood what was the
relationships like with the parents and
it's amazing how much
how how much
health you can gain with your money when
you realize that and go oh that's why i
do this absolutely and money we say it
around here all the time
you know it's usually never about money
usually there's things underneath what's
going on whether it's a motivation you
have a fear you have a relational issue
you have like
but sometimes it comes out as a money
problem and so it's fascinating to kind
of dig under those layers because like
you said you know when you become
healthier as a person
and you can navigate okay why i do
certain things then you can change
your bad habits into better ones and
kind of figure out how to navigate um
with the cards that have been dealt with
you know to you and the same is true
with your money that's fascinating we
see that on the ramsay show a lot people
call in with a money question it turns
out it's a relationship question that's
right that's right and so we're happy to
take those calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five me and rachel we
will dig with a scalpel to the root
issue to help you out and james kicks
off this hour in salt lake city james
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are you guys we're doing great
how can we help
hey so i've got a question on student
loan debt so
my wife and i have been paying off we're
on baby set two we've paid off about 27
000
in 18 months
thanks
sorry um so it's been an emotional
journey since the current administration
put the pause on student loan debt we've
taken all that stuff since we're
debt-free except for student loans and
we've been dropping into savings we've
got about ten thousand dollars
and since things are starting back up
we're wondering should we dump all of
that into it or save a little bit kind
of like baby step three
so you're saying can i can i skip and
leap frog to baby step three while i'm
still paying off the student loans
yeah when they pause the interest and
everything my wife and i gauged out the
risk of the potential
of them doing the 50 000 forgiveness and
if we were dumping everything into it
it'd be a loss whereas right now since
there's no interest we're putting into
savings so that way if it didn't get
wiped out we could just put all that
into the student loans how much do you
guys have left james
thirty seven thousand okay
well um
you may not like our answer
james uh i wouldn't i know it's okay i
mean i feel like you knew it a little
bit but here's what i'm going to tell
you
i would not bank on the government to
forgive your student loans whether it's
10 or 50 000 i want you to take control
there's a level of mojo that you get
back when you decide you know what i'm
gonna handle this thing
i can get out of this and i don't need
anyone's help other than my own work
ethic my own sacrifice to do this so
you've got ten thousand dollars saved
you have thirty seven thousand dollars
left in debt correct
correct okay so if you want to do things
the ramsey way and i don't say that
because i'm a ramsey man i say because
it's the proven way that people have
gotten out of debt the people that you
hear on these debt-free screams so what
that means is you're going to be
setting aside 1 000 of the 10 000 for
your baby step one starter emergency
fund and that's going to leave you with
9 000 to throw at the remaining 37
which by my math takes you down to what
28
correct and how much do you guys make a
year james
uh 45 000. 45. and do you guys have any
kids
i've got two little girls and we live
with our in-laws right now so we've got
about thirteen thousand dollars we've
been putting into our savings each month
thirteen thousand
oh sorry no thirteen hundred times oh i
was like man that's incredible let's get
rid of these student loans okay so
i would love to have thirteen thousand
to put in every month so your expenses
must be really low
yeah so we just have like our basic
stuff we don't have any car loans or
credit card debt or anything like that
it's just student loans
yeah i mean can you can either one of
you maybe take on a side job and try to
get a little more income while we get
these student loans paid off
yeah so we just paid off
probably about five thousand dollars in
medical debt i drive uber eats on the
side
and so that's really helped with that
and so now all that can start going
towards student loan debt as well so
james what do you guys do if you're
making 45 household you and your wife
what do you guys do
um so i actually work in sales and
account management for a company here in
salt lake my wife doesn't work right now
just some stuff that she's going through
right now she was a school teacher
we also were on a waiting list for a
sweat equity
home building program
and they just recommended because she's
not going to work once we get into it
that she wasn't necessarily working when
we got into that program what's that
program about
so essentially it's it's a sweat equity
program where about 10 families get
together
through a non-profit and we actually
build each other's homes
it allows us to get into a home for
about 200 000 on a mortgage for 400 000
home
so it's just
can't do you have to be at a certain
income in order to qualify for that
yeah yeah so we'd still be within the
income but they said that she won't work
when she's up there
they just didn't recommend that she work
when we were on
james yeah i don't know i'm not liking
this i don't like the fact that you have
to limit your income i know this this
feels odd to me
yeah i know but james you can get a 200
you can get an incredible mortgage or a
credible house that doesn't have to be a
400 000 house what i'm feeling is that
you're you're yielding to other people
you're yielding to the government to pay
off the student loans you're yielding to
this program for a home james you and
your wife can do this you guys are smart
you can be
you can
rent for a little bit move out of your
in-laws let her work
you guys get this income up wipe off the
student loan save up for a down payment
i mean y'all could live the american
dream you can do this yes i'm getting
exciting just here excited just hearing
rachel talk about this stuff you can do
this man put the ball back in your
course yes don't limit yourself don't
let me your income don't wait on the
government take control bring up that
income get rid of these student loans
live life on your terms this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
four
three
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast on the ramsey network joined
today by rachel cruz host of the rachel
cruz show also a wonderful show you can
find on the ramsey network and i had the
pleasure of recording a segment with you
yesterday for the show know we did want
ooh about buying it's gonna be great how
companies are going after your money and
how you can protect yourself yes take
control
because i mean
people think of ramsay as like oh yeah
y'all are
cheap and you don't spend any money and
all that we're like no no listen we are
all about creating a life that you love
yes you will cut your lifestyle down
and be cheap when you're getting out of
debt and getting an emergency fund
there's there's appropriate times for
that but then there's also
times that you get to celebrate and
actually enjoy but you still even then
don't want to waste your money and
companies know how to market so well to
you where you spend and you almost don't
even realize you're spending you're
spending more than you should and all of
it so george you're the expert on it and
we broke it all down
okay i want my single origin coffee and
you like to shop and travel and have all
these great experiences inexpensive not
just affordable and inexpensive
affordable we can do that well that's
what we're here for we'll help you with
your money problems your money questions
we'll celebrate with you we love to do
that here on the ramsey show and we are
going to the lines this hour we've got
sarah in terre haute indiana sarah
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call it's
great to talk to you guys we're happy to
talk my husband
thank you my husband and i are on baby
steps four and six we do not have
children so we're not doing baby step
five
um i recently was terminated last week
from my 20-year career as a college
instructor wow sarah
wasn't here was it unexpected
yes i opted out of the production and i
had a religious exemption
and they still
because of that were unable to use me
moving forward
so it was considered determination
i'm meeting with an attorney he's asking
me if he's able to help me legally what
should i ask for
in terms of
being terminated and if that was a
wrongful termination should i ask for
obviously my job back
but if that's not an option um he wanted
to know
you know would i want retirement what i
want you know wages and i just wondered
what your thoughts were on
um how to approach that
well would you want your job back if
they offered it to
you um it's a sticky situation because
um being unvaccinated that's not a
favorable
position to be in at that particular
employer
that was my guess was that even if they
offered it back to you which would i
don't know it feels like a pipe dream at
this point or do you want to even be
with that employer again
are there job options out there
well i'm currently applying for other
job options um you know that that are
comfortable i did have a religious
exemption that was accepted
and it still didn't work out for
employment um
so well as far as the severance goes
have you talked to anyone else who's
been in this situation to see what they
ended up with if anything
no this is an unusual circumstance in my
little community and i don't know
i don't even know what a severance
package looks like or
you know what that would entail
um
so he said other than my job back what
type of negotiating uh things would i
ask for if this is deemed you know not
making reasonable accommodations
and i don't even know what that would be
like would i ask for salary retirement
i don't know yeah i mean i feel like
usually when there's a termination with
severance and a company i mean obviously
companies can do what they want but
considering how long you've been there
20 plus years
i mean yeah having having a a year's
worth um of income i feel like is yeah
that sounds fair for that length of time
like rachel said they can they can do
whatever they want but if they want to
be kind and
do a nice thing i think a year's worth
would be fair to ask for
they didn't offer you anything um sarah
when they let you go
no because it was a termination
it wasn't a resignation or retirement
i'm three years from retirement
um and so i even asked about early
retirement and
and because it's a hot topic and the
vaccine right now is a really
you know sticky situation um
that was not offered yeah
so
well here's the thing
i think you can ask for whatever you
think is fair uh if you want to make it
you know uh
you want to kind of make them the poster
child and go we're going to go after
them for a million dollars because of
this that's something you can do but if
you're saying like what is reasonable
and what do i need yeah that's going to
depend on your financial situation and
you know if you're this close to
retirement are you doing okay for
retirement are you doing okay
financially do you have an emergency
fund
yes we have a six-month emergency fund
we my husband and i together have almost
500 000 in retirement
um and so the retirement package at this
employer was amazing they contributed 15
percent of my income of their money into
an en into a 403 b so i've been very
blessed that you know for 20 years i've
had excellent retirement plus what my
husband and i put in you know on top of
that at the 15 that we do for baby step
four
yeah so you guys
that's what's hurting you have about
half a million total for retirement
between both of you yeah okay i feel
like close to that yeah you probably you
both of you will probably need to
continue working to make sure you've got
a good nest egg for retirement if if
you're saying it is three years away
so make sure you're in control there but
if i'm you i would ask for a year uh i
don't know how far you want to push it
as far as the lawyer goes i personally
probably wouldn't i would say hey if
they whatever they're willing to do is
fine but if you want to go further than
that that's going to be a decision
you've got to make with with the
attorney so but i would find out what
are what's happening in the area what
are other people asking for what are
they actually getting and try to get
some yeah i would do a little research
too because again this is a topic that
people are dealing with literally as we
speak we took two calls about the same
thing yesterday so i'm like there it's
it's a new unprecedented like that's the
word that we've been using new ground
but it is and i'm like you know we're
all learning from it right we don't like
there is not this pattern that we can
look back over 10 years here's what has
happened what you can do sarah i think
is gather information
um obviously talk to your attorney and
but i would see what else is happening
because there's other
sectors out there that people are
leaving because of this exact issue and
to see
okay what does that look like in the
education space so as much information
as you can gather i think would be wise
well our question from the day comes
from blinds.com blinds.com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from garrett and
florida i know ramsey solutions teaches
that building capital without ever using
credit is better than the best credit
score i've worked hard and been very
disciplined and followed the principal
i'm 31 years old with close to 2 million
in assets and investments i have no
payment history because my current job
provides housing i want to buy my own
home soon so what is the best way to
purchase a house and what should i do to
build up my credit score those are two
very different questions what's the best
way to purchase a house without a credit
score and what should i do to build it
up i'm going to tell you the second one
you don't need to do at all there's a
process that we talk about here on the
show a lot called manual underwriting or
a no score loan and we've recommended
our friends at church home mortgage for
years because they are expert at this
and they're one of the good guys out
there who can help you do this without a
credit score and rachel this isn't
theory i did this yes that's right i got
my mortgage without having a credit
score because i had paid off my debt and
my score became indeterminable and we
actually dug into this very topic on the
latest episode of the fine print the
dirty truth behind your credit score oh
i love it and i tried it
we got the juice so i called the
apartments all over the country rentals
and said hey i don't have a credit score
can i rent from you and they went uh
yeah do you have a job oh you're not a
criminal okay great and i was like oh
okay so it's not harder than you think
yeah yeah there may be a higher deposit
things like that and then i talked to uh
my friend seth at churchill mortgage and
he explained to me the manual
underwriting process what's entailed um
you know it's a little bit lengthier
because it's manual they have to
actually go through your real life and
go all right you've got utility bills
you've been paying on here's your w-2s
so there's some real factors involved
versus oh the bank said i can have a
half million dollars right right right
that's never a good way to go about it
so my man you got two million dollars in
assets at 31 you're crushing it but
here's the deal don't build up the
credit score just use manual
underwriting you can use a place like
churchill mortgage there's lots of
places that do it look around do your
research and uh get this mortgage paid
off if you've got two million maybe you
buy a house in cash who needs a credit
score then turns out you only need a
credit score when you want debt rachel
that's right george fascinating stuff
groundbreaking this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
four
three
[Music]
this is the ramsay show open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five i'm george campbell she's
rachel cruz and on the line we've got
jamie in seattle washington jamie i see
on my screen
you're debt free
i am debt free i love to hear it
okay so how much have you paid off
i have paid off thirty five thousand
dollars
love it how long did that take
uh three years
and what was your range of income during
that time
well that's the best part of the story
when i started out i was completely
upside down i was taking care of my
elderly parents my two young sons all on
my own making about uh
50 to 55 000 a year
wow
yeah so 50 to 55 was the range during
those three years
yeah i started my budget completely
upside down i was sponsored by my aunt
and uncle who teach the program and i'm
so grateful it was really a challenge
because i didn't even have enough money
to pay all the bills wow but with hard
work and
dedication and commitment i kept
plugging forward and when i made the
decision that i had breathing room and i
really
needed to tithe at that point
about three months into
taking that tithe challenge to give back
to god
i had my former employer come back to me
and say hey we really want you back in a
consulting
capacity i had started my own business
and i had built it up so i went from
making 50 000 a year in my own business
to having my own business and having
another consulting job and making a
hundred and fifty a year whoa
free jamie that's incredible so when did
you when did you start making 150 was it
towards the end of this journey
uh it was actually towards the end of
the journey it was just uh this last uh
summer just before summer you're a rock
star
that
i i took that on and god really blessed
me i felt like when i made the decision
to start tithing he said hey you're
doing great with what i gave you here's
some more
so now i get to share the program with
my family i get to share it with my
employees and one of my employees has
started the program this month
because they've seen the huge change
that it's made in my life as a single
mom
and part of the sandwich generation
trying to take care of elderly parents
and young kids and
it takes work and it's so hard at the
beginning but it is so worth it and i
encourage people to
take the risk be vulnerable
get help go through the program
because it will change your life like
it's changed mine jamie let me say this
here's what's impressive to me it's not
that you are making a hundred and fifty
thousand and paid off thirty five
thousand three years you're making 50
000
paid off 35 000 in three years and
toward the end of that is you got that
tremendous 100 000 raise basically yeah
uh which is which is just it's amazing
and i love the faithfulness of what
you've said like you have walked and
been faithful with the little and you
put in the sweat and the tears and the
grind and the hardship and i'm sure
there were some days that were way
harder than others
victories and setbacks all of it through
those three years and it's like that
built this character in you jamie really
to know what it takes to win and a level
of gratitude and then you put on a
hundred thousand dollars on top of it
toward the end and it's just and it's
like you can handle that you know what i
mean like yeah there's just something so
beautiful about that journey even though
i know it was so hard um it's remarkable
so well done yeah well done thank you so
much what kind of debt was this
um it was you know
some legal debt some medical debt um
some just poor decisions on trying to
you know charge things because i didn't
have enough money to
buy the kids things or to get mom and
dad medication that they needed those
kind of things so you know it was pretty
much just getting into a pattern of
relying on credit cards to fill the gap
when i didn't have the cash but i'm so
glad that i started because especially
with you know coming out of 2020 it
slowed me down a bit but i didn't stop
i knew
immediately once that snowball started
happening that this was going to change
my life
drastically and now on to step three
i'm already you know a third of the way
through to my goal and um i'm just i'm
so
incredibly grateful and i am
leaving a legacy to my kids because my
kids are six and four and they have both
already accomplished step one
and so that's that's something that i
want to pass on to them because i went
from having no idea how to manage money
to having so much confidence in the way
that i manage my money and that i
give it back to the lord and that he has
blessed it and
he blesses the hard work that you put
into it so what happened jamie 36 months
ago because you had a lot of life
happening like you said you're taking
care of parents you don't have enough
money to pay the bills i mean you were
in a tough spot so it would have been
easy to kind of just give up and say
this is my life and this is how it's
going to have to be but you didn't 36
months ago you made a choice so tell me
what happened
then to change everything
well my um when our youngest was one um
uh steve passed away my partner had
passed away so i was genuinely on my own
um and i was
terrified and at my wits end but i was
also in a place of submission where i
knew god i can't get out of this without
you
and um my aunt and uncle melon phil
dameron came alongside me and said hey
we want to sponsor you to take this
class we think it'll change your life
just give us
a chance and it was hard like doing my
budget with them i wept i was so
embarrassed it's very hard to be
vulnerable like that in front of people
um and and to you know own some of the
poor financial decisions that i was
making but they were so patient and so
loving and were there for me and were
accountability partners for me um and i
can't thank them enough
that's amazing you're you're remarkable
jamie i mean you had you had
someone you know your partner said the
death
of him you're taking care of your
parents you have two little kids i mean
you're you're remarkable i mean that is
that's a lot of hard life that you
walked through and
and yet you came out on the other side
choosing to to put your time and your
energy and your effort into something
like this to
to get you back in control right like
there's a level that i'm sure you feel
in control of because because how are
you feeling now i mean for 36 months ago
jamie's sitting there doing her first
budget to now what how do you feel
it's it's amazing i am so grateful
uh to dave and the program i'm so
grateful i get to share it with others
i feel
secure i'm not
constantly terrified or struggling with
anxiety i got to take my kids on
vacation this last summer i am getting
to give them all the benefits that other
people have i turned a very low income
single income into a two-income
household and i am just i feel confident
i feel
um excited for the future because i know
that i'm i'm safe and especially in the
economy that we're struggling in right
now i'm so grateful i did it and it
doesn't matter where you're starting
from it doesn't matter how deep you are
in the hole all you need to do is commit
to it and um you know god has has
blessed that commitment in my life and i
just want to share it with other people
let them know it is so worth it
wow
you're incredible jamie you know they
say that uh having a testimony is great
getting one sucks and you've been
through it but now you have an
incredible story to share especially
with other single moms people who have
been through some stuff people who are
taking care of their parents and you can
say listen you can do this and i know
that because i did it and so we are so
proud of you we're honored to be able to
share your story and we're just pumped
for what's next for you so we've got a
copy of the legacy journey you told me
that you want to change the legacy of
your kids you're doing that you have
done that you will continue to do that
and so we want to send you a copy of
that as well as a copy of the total
money makeover and you can sponsor
someone else's journey and take them
along and show them that it's possible
that they don't have to live with the
stress and anxiety of finances in their
life
and uh we're just pumped for you to pay
this thing forward and keep living your
life you ready for this well thank you
so much i am okay let's uh let's get to
it it's jamie from seattle washington
paid off 35 000 in three years making 50
up to a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars count it down jamie let's hear a
debt free scream
i'm done
what an inspiration amazing amazing do
you know what's so interesting and it's
happened both debt free calls and
yesterday even i feel like people get
raises yeah when they're on a journey
and they have a goal there's something
about it that just shifts in your life
that i feel like people catch on to yeah
i don't think it's ebgb there's just
this level where you start to take
control and start to manage your money
well you intend you tend to get more
pops in your hands look at that what an
inspiration jamie thank you for the call
and congrats on debt freedom this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
four
three
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm george campbell joined today by
rachel cruz this is the ramsey show open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five we were having a
good time we're gonna keep it going with
ryan in kansas city ryan welcome to the
ramsay show
hey how are you guys doing doing great
how can we help
um yeah so i'm trying to figure out what
baby step i'm in
i'm currently
i i feel like i've paid off a lot of
baby step two
but
i'm kind of stuck with a business and
trying to figure out
um the baby steps and how i can apply
that in the business world okay what's
your business
so it's a
like an animal care
facility okay so boarding and things
like that
yep all right veterinarian clinic
very nice and so you've got some debt
that's tied to the business
correct i've got debt tied to the
business we purchased and the real
estate because that the business is on
but then on my personal side all i have
is my house and
some land that we hope to someday build
a house off
okay so we've kind of got two two
payments going on in your personal life
for the mortgage in the land
yep and then the business debt what's
your household income
um if we combined the business and
personal and everything it's close to
400 000. wow fantastic
okay is that mostly from this uh this
animal care business
yes
all right yes uh it's about a hundred
thousand personal and then the rest is
the business side and you signed for
this under your name right
on the business side
okay so this is your debt
absolutely all right so we're going to
treat this thing you know we're going to
put in the debt snowball other than your
primary mortgage and you said you want
to keep this land you want to build on
it eventually right
correct so when you list out your debts
from smallest to largest what would that
look like what is that smallest debt
right now
i guess my house
oh your house is the smallest
yes
and then what is on the business side
are we talking half a million
um
so the business side is about 750 with a
real estate of 200.
okay so 750 total and the real estate
amounts to 200
yes what's the other part of that the
rest of the 750
uh the land mp land that we have
oh
okay okay okay
so i mean if i'm you the business debt
while it's important you've got 400 000
coming in what are you doing with the
excess amount right now are you putting
some away for retained earnings for your
business to make new hires what's going
on with the excess
well and that's kind of where i was
stuck at first we were really attacking
our baby step two with cars and we're
going to really get that and now that
we've kind of got past all that
i i didn't
with all kovid and all the different
variants of this come out i'm just i i
don't know how much to keep in there the
so-called emergency fund for a business
and then i really want to start
attacking the debt with uh
the the money i have saved because right
now it's kind of setting in a business
account
and i want to start using it
yeah
well if your business is in good shape
and you've got some retained earnings
when you can attack that mortgage and
get rid of your primary residence
and then attack this business debt
if something goes bad with the business
i mean you could sell that property
right
correct so you're in okay shape on that
side uh but your primary residence i
would attack that first rachel and get
that out of the way which is going to
hopefully free up a good chunk of money
and you can kind of continue on you
don't really have a lot of consumer debt
there's just a whole lot of real estate
going on here
correct yeah correct and i've got i got
a lot in the bank saved and i just i was
i just didn't know how much is
considered um if i should save like a
three or six month or do a six month due
to um
covid causing a little bit more
hesitation sure and then how much what
is considered the six month like a
skeleton
you know that's just paying the building
paying the loan paying utility i would
say if you're able to pay all the
whoever's on staff pay all the bills
keep all the you can keep the whole
business running for six months and
you've got that in savings you're in a
good spot there anything beyond that
unless you're trying to make a you know
upgrade purchase make a new hire that's
when you want to make sure that you've
got the cash flow and the money set
aside to do things like that
so if i'm you i'm paying off the house
first you've got a fantastic income
thanks to this business so i would use
that to your benefit and not get crazy
doing upgrades and things like that i
mean what we teach an entree leadership
which is dave's playbook on how he's
built ramsey solutions to what it is
today over a thousand team members
we teach you to run your business
debt-free and so obviously we're already
in this thing we've got some debt
happening right but you're not in a
terrible situation there's nothing on
fire here so i would just encourage you
to try to get to that point where you
can run your business debt-free we've
got lots of resources over at entree
leadership i host the entree leadership
podcast dave and i actually did an
episode recently on budgeting for
business and kind of this financial
piece for business
and inside of entre leadership elite
which is our online membership we've got
a huge video library where we dig into
how to run the financials for your
business we've got advisory groups that
you can jump into in there where you can
be around other business owners uh
virtually in coaching calls and our
coaches here can help you navigate all
the challenges of running a business
um when i start thinking about baby step
three putting money
into
retirement uh we really would like to
start doing that more
what
income do i base that off our income
that we currently make or with the
business also
well your income is your income if you
make 400 000 a year and whatever's on
your taxes that's what i want you to be
able to get your take on
yeah so if you if you make that all of
it combined yes and so i'd put away 15
of course you've got lots of options as
a as a business owner if you're
self-employed all those things you can
look into solo 401ks and seps and all
that good stuff so you're doing great
man you got a great income on this thing
and you just got to clean up some of
this mess with the debt and try to run
it debt-free way to go thanks for the
call nicole joined us in los angeles and
nicole welcome to the ramsay show
hi sir how are you doing great how can
rachel and i help
hi rachel um
well okay so my question is i am
starting fpu and i'm i've been
contributing um with an employer match
of four percent to my deferred comp um i
know we're not supposed to be investing
until baby step four so i i'm wondering
if i should stop the four percent match
i've been doing it since i was 21 years
old i really am not missing that money
but i i don't know what the right way is
yeah nicole how much debt do you have
well i've been doing uh dave ish for a
very long time and i've paid off 54 000
and i still have 73
and change okay what is the 73
um car loan
and
silly debt you know credit cards and
nonsense like that yeah i don't own a
home
i have three kids i'm a single mom
my oldest is in college i've been
cashflowing that and i'm my second
is about to start college next year and
that's
my challenge okay and how much do you
make a year
um between 180 and 200. that's great
what do you do
i'm a supervisor in law enforcement and
that's what's uh
wonderful yeah wonderful
well you make a great income nicole but
like you said i mean you've been making
a great income and still in this
stagnant place i mean is what it feels
like and so i think for you one of the
biggest
changes that has to happen is is
something honestly within to say okay
i'm done i'm done messing around with
the car loans and the credit cards
and just it's a little bit just kind of
being sloppy you know i mean
and again this is that's not to to shame
you but i i see this income and i see
the debt and you've already paid off 54
but you still have 73.
and so there's something about it nicole
that if you if you just got so focused
which means yes pausing the investing
which i know you've been doing since 21
again and you're not stopping it forever
you're just pausing
i mean and maybe even look whatever you
know your car maybe you sell the car and
you look to say okay i'm going to clean
this up i'm going to live on a budget
because you're you have a great income
nicole like you're going to be able to
do a lot
but it's going to take about a year or
so to kind of just tighten everything up
and to say okay
i'm going to get rid of the access i'm
going to and that may even mean for your
kids to say you know i'm gonna pause the
college stuff but we we talk about
student loans on here all the time
though how they can still
go to school debt-free but i want you as
as a woman as a single mom to get this
stuff under control but you really have
to make this decision it's no more ish
you got to be all in and it's going to
take some effort
but i'm telling you within 12 months you
have this entire thing turned around oh
yeah it's amazing how when you slow down
on the investing side you can speed up
your financial future yeah and actually
live on a budget you can do this nicole
you can live within this i love it
beautifully said that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books my thanks
to our board engineer ben hill acting
producer kelly daniel we will be back
with you before you know it from now
rachel cruz america it's been a fun hour
we'll be back with you this is the
ramsey show hey it's kelly associate
producer and phone screener for the
ramsay show if you would like to do your
debt free scream live on the show make
sure you visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story
four three
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm ramsay personality george
campbell host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast joined today
by rachel cruz best-selling author host
of the racial crew show
ramsay personality all the things
she
she's a mother she's a friend
she's a wife it's great it was fun
rachel a lot of people don't know this
both of our spouses work here at ramsey
solutions that is true i think that's
special and you and whitney you all met
here right we met here yes it's a lovely
uh there's been two engagements that
i've known
of people that i've worked on team like
within the last six weeks that have met
their spouse here yeah i have a joke we
have our endorsed local providers i've
joked that we need an app that's
endorsed love providers and it's like a
matchmaking service
ben hill is in the booth
saying no shaking his head no no hey
it's it's pretty it's a real thing we
got a lot of young people a lot of young
people and we we say that we only hire
thoroughbreds instead of donkeys and so
a lot of great quality people here at
ramsey solutions and so uh love it has
been known to be in the air that's all
i'm gonna say we're throwing it out
there you know so this could be the this
could be the love hour you and i could
give marriage dating advice that would
be fun call us up with those questions
triple eight eight two five five two two
five or just money questions is fine too
but that would be a fun hour you have
the money in marriage event we should do
like a switch with john and ken
so we need to find something like i'll
do like fashion like what's your thing
like me like
what's like what's your thing that like
we could stump
two of the other person we do like a
switch theme hour they got to answer
questions of things that we know and
then we gotta answer questions like we
gotta be interested in the culture does
that make sense yeah i don't know i'm
feeling good about that all right we'll
pitch it one picture today's not here
dave's not here we shall try
it's so fun well we are starting off
this hour with gavin in san antonio
texas gavin welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are y'all doing doing great how
can we help
hey so um
i'm going to try to put it into words
but it's going to make more sense as we
go along here but my big question as of
right now is uh i'm a young guy and i've
saved a pretty good amount of money here
and i'm looking to figure out
what is the
fastest and safest
way to go ahead uh and build this wealth
here and
you know i know we're gonna get into the
uh the baby steps here but uh you know i
i do have some questions about them in
regards to achieving this goal okay how
young are you i'm 24 years old what's
your household income
uh right now i make about 80 000 a year
okay and how much wealth have you
amassed so far um i have about
40 to 42 000 in uh just apple stock i
have another 2 000 uh another individual
stock about 11 000 in my roth ira
and about 3 000 sitting in the bank so i
think that's roughly about 60. okay and
you don't have any consumer debt
no sir i have no debt at all and you've
got a fully funded emergency fund it
sounds like you have 3 000 savings
uh i have a like a small one i have like
the thousand dollar emergency fund but
not like i wouldn't say i haven't
established three to six months one just
yet
is there a reason why you skipped over
that one or
um
to be honest i kind of uh i became a fan
of y'all just fairly recently so that's
kind of why that worked out that way i'm
actually like that's my next step right
now is to go ahead and build that three
to six month fund
i'm currently
using my gi bill i'm a veteran
and i'm going to school for computer
science right now very cool thank you
for your service yeah well gavin you've
done an incredible job i mean you're
you're making 80k you have
you have you know
a great nest egg here i mean you and as
young as you are no debt i mean like you
really are um i can tell you're
motivated and so i love
your question i would say on a tactical
level
um i would use some of this stock that
you have just to cash out some of it
just so go ahead and just get an
emergency fund today i mean you could
just go ahead and put some of that in a
money market account along with that 3k
you have a thousand dollars and you have
3 000 bank i mean you can combine a
little bit of this take some of that
stock out um
but i'll say this gavin after
you know we've been doing this ramsey
solutions for over three decades helping
people build wealth and you are
well on your way for sure to do that
um but i think a couple of things get in
the way of that and that can can kind of
um train wreck this for some people
um number one is is greed and number two
is impatience
and those sometimes go hand in hand and
so my encouragement to you would be that
what we have found on our everyday
millionaires doing this stuff is that
being wealthy and or getting wealthy
right building um
building a huge nest egg
it takes a little bit of time and it's
more like a marathon it's not a sprint
and it's not going to be
super cool it's not going to be these
little secrets and these well you do
this and put your money here and you're
going to turn again this investment
they're going to reinvent
all this stuff it's actually really
boring gavin like like the way we teach
it because
the way we do that is because there's a
proven process and you want to have a
long track record on something to say
hey
this is what we do so what we have found
is people are building their wealth by
just traditional investing so you're
doing your roth ira which is awesome
if your company doesn't match your 401k
but doing these traditional retirement
routes is awesome and then going in and
saying hey okay let's look at just a
good growth stock mutual funds let's
look at some other things so instead of
having these single stocks
that carry more risk because it's one
thing even though i know it's apple
right and you could say walmart but
but there is a level where you're saying
okay i'm i am
i'm putting a lot of my eggs in one
basket versus diversifying like a good
mutual fund would have 90 to 200 stocks
apple could be included in that but but
90 to 200 companies and so that's it's a
more conservative approach but it's one
that is going to be able to take lower
that risk now we do say when you're once
you're on baby step seven which means
you have no mortgage you have no
payments
then you can take about 10 of your of
your net worth and kind of just have a
little bit of fun with that so whatever
that looks like for you maybe that's
yeah buying a single stock here or there
it's not something that i we advise
though
on on
the front end by any means so
um the wealth building that we teach
it's not super glamorous it's not the
sexiest but it but it but it works is
what i'm saying it works my husband had
this is what we've done we've done this
for 12 years
we're in baby step 7 and we we throw as
much money we max out everything every
year 401k roth iras we have another
mutual fund we put we have
a vanguard account we have stuff spread
around but when we just we just we save
money and then the other turned to gavin
i'll just add it and then george i'm
sorry you can jump in but it is the
generous piece too gavin i want you to
be giving at this point too because
there is something to be said that
yes building wealth is fun buying stuff
is fun going on vacations is fun all of
it
but nothing nothing changes you like
writing a check for a ten thousand
dollar car and buying someone who needs
a car car just because you can i mean
there's there's things like that that i
want you to
to weave into your story and your money
plan as well yeah gavin do you own a
house yeah
um so no currently um i'm currently
living with family and my big thing is
that because i'm still in school you
know i'm having kind of a set target day
here to graduate my theory was was that
because i'm in san antonio it's not
exactly the big technology hub oh yeah
um i i figured i wanted to be open
here's why
i want you to have a paid for house uh
before you jump into some fun times
investing so that would be my next goal
from you that's going to be your fastest
path to wealth is not having a payment
whether it's rent or a mortgage so
that'd be my next goal man but you're
doing great but just do things in the
right order to set yourself up for
success this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
five
four
three
[Music]
right now you're probably focused on all
the false stuff you've gotta buy the
halloween candy the jackets and the
sweaters but here's what you should
start thinking about right now christmas
i know christmas seems to sneak up on
people every year and when you let that
happen it's so easy to go crazy on
overspending or worse put christmas on a
credit card don't do that but when you
plan ahead with a budget you'll keep
christmas from getting out of control
and the best way to do that is with our
budgeting tool every dollar start your
christmas budget now by deciding how
much you want to save each month and
plug that into your every dollar budget
so you can pay for christmas in cash
then when you start shopping your every
dollar makes it easy to keep up with how
much you're spending on gifts and by the
way it's totally free to get started or
you can upgrade to a ramsey plus
membership and get premium features like
bank sync that allows you to just drag
and drop your transactions into your
budget and all kinds of custom reports
to show you where your money's going
guys christmas is coming it's not a
surprise
this year you can enjoy the holiday how
it should be
stress free and debt free start
budgeting with every dollar by texting
the word budget to
33789 that's budget to 33789
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i'm george
campbell joined today by rachel cruz
jared joins us in fayetteville north
carolina jared welcome to the ramsay
show
hey guys how y'all doing today doing
great how can we help
well i got a quick two-part question but
first i got to say george i think your
ideas that your business love providers
a fantastic idea
we have one vote for my matchmaking
program from ramsey jared says yes he's
actually going to buy into the idea
thanks jared you can be the first hill
is still in the booth shaking his head
no don't don't encourage him well jared
that's that's for another day how can we
help today
hey yeah so i've got a question about uh
some investing so i'm on baby step four
and i'm at the stage where i should be
putting 15 percent into my um
retirement investing
uh i'm in the army so i get the five
percent match for my psp
hey can you hear me now yeah that's a
little better
so you get five percent match
yeah so um the army offers me the five
percent match based on my um
based on what i put in
is that five percent plus if i were to
put just 10 in equal to 15 or do i need
to put 15 of my own in and then the 5 is
just extra yeah it's an age-old question
and it's a good one uh and there are
some caveats to this but when it's just
an employer match we like to look at
that as icing on the cake so i still
want you contributing 15 of your
household income into a good retirement
account and treat that match just as
bonus because we don't have full control
we don't know if that's going to change
you might change your employment status
down the line and i want this to be a
consistent part of your financial
picture sure that makes sense and a
quick second part was i'm looking at a
small uh re-enlistment bonus in the next
couple of months and i was wondering if
that should go toward my current baby
step baby step four or paying off the
house all right so you've got a mortgage
as well
that's right
yeah i would put that towards the house
i mean as long as you're contributing 15
of your household income if you've got a
bonus coming in like that you can
allocate that and go hey we're gonna
knock down the mortgage a little bit to
uh to speed up this process
cool okay well that answer is basically
best part of my question so i appreciate
y'all awesome thanks for your service
yes thank you so much man thanks for the
call fantastic christina is in uh los
angeles christina welcome to the ramsay
show
hi george hi rachel um my question is
that my husband and i are debating
whether to purchase a house
i love a good debate
yeah what's the debate about kind of
um i don't think we can afford it that's
my issue um we live in a one-bedroom
apartment i'm pregnant
um so it's a single-family income my
husband's take-home is about 5000 a
month
okay and
we have no debt thankfully and we have
70 000 in savings but the house is
around here
for just a two bed one bath is about
380.
yeah i mean you're in a you're in a
you're in la right
uh we're just outside but it's still
just as expensive yeah
going up yeah it's southern california
so your pay is five grand total and
that's probably not changing anytime
soon
no it doesn't seem to be changing
anytime soon
okay well the parameters we recommend
and i'll tell you why we recommend them
uh is to stick to a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage where the mortgage payment is
no more than a quarter of your take-home
pay so in this instance you'd be looking
at trying to get your payment to around
1250 on a 15-year fixed now if you if
you do the math on that you're going
okay well that means we can afford
nothing in in the los angeles area and
so what that means to me is exactly what
i was thinking what that means to me is
you just need to buy yourself some
patience and it may mean that we need a
bigger down payment so you said you had
70 right
we had 70 we don't have enough for the
20 and to avoid the pmi yeah
my husband wants to do a 30-year fix but
i
following the steps he's fairly new to
them um i'm i would want the 15 year
sure but that means staying in our tiny
apartment which is about 450 square feet
with a baby on the way yeah is there is
there any other move that you could make
that is more lateral that could get you
more room maybe you're further outside
of the city where's his work in
proximity to all this
well he was commuting in downtown l.a
and the commute was killing him
um he works in downtown l.a
he was he found a new job closer but
it's the same pay
so we'll be saving uh on transportation
but he we really don't want to want him
to commute anymore yeah it was just too
rough yep
and this is one of the hard things i
feel like
depending on where you live because
there's just certain
parts of the country you know that it's
it's going to be more expensive and so
the reason we have these parameters and
and we always kind of laugh not to poke
fun of california but we're always like
just because you live in california
doesn't mean you're exempt from math so
the formula still works no matter where
you live
um is what george is saying it's either
going to just take more time and and how
old are you guys
uh we're 34 35 okay we're having our
first child awesome well congratulations
unexpecting that's very exciting very
very exciting so yeah i mean i
i would always say you don't have one or
two it's not like we can buy a house we
can't buy a house and we have to stay in
this one bedroom and that's it you have
other options so you guys i would shop
around and even if it adds an extra
15-20 minutes to go and rent a
two-bedroom give yourself a little bit
more space if it's in the budget you're
able to spread out a little bit more if
you can uh especially with that baby
coming and then you guys have a game
plan to say okay you know what our goal
is in the next
i don't know what it is for you guys
maybe it's five years maybe it's maybe
it's eight years that we're gonna buy a
home but because of the part of the
country you're in it is more expensive
and
again you guys are making you know
you're making 60 000
um
which is great uh but it but again equal
to the standard of living
and the expenses in somewhere like
southern california it goes quickly
that money does so
you guys want this house when you decide
to purchase because i always encourage
home ownership to get to a point where
you guys can do this because it's just a
great investment i think it's i think
it's something that's really wise to put
your money towards um
but you guys it needs to be a blessing
not a curse and when you stretch
yourself so thin
um it starts to be that curse so set
yourself up and just have patience and
listen if you're renting again even if
it's for five more years you're not
throwing money down the drain you're
setting yourself up to be wise but it's
going to take a lot of patience
christina
and and i and i know starting a family
and all that it's going to make you want
to have a home even that much more
but listen let the money and the numbers
be there and
again i hate to say it you guys aren't
exempt from math but it does kind of
stink when you talk to someone who's in
miami or up in the northeast or southern
california because it is what it is the
real estate is just it's more expensive
christina pop over to
ramseysolutions.com and click on
mortgage calculator that's what i was
doing over here just to try to see where
you guys would need to be at and it
looks like you just need to say keep
saving up that down payment i know 70
000 is amazing you might need 120 you
might need 130 in order to get a house
in your area that's within your budget
you can also have your husband listen to
our fine print episode is now the worst
time to buy a house rachel cruz was
featured on there and she talks through
the green lights of what it would take
to get into that house so it's the
perfect episode for him to check out you
can go to fineprintpodcast.com
and search for that episode listen to it
with him and maybe it'll slow him down
and go all right you're right we got to
do this thing the right way so the house
is a blessing not a curse this is the
ramsay show
[Applause]
six
five
4
3.
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell host of the fine print
um and entree leadership podcast joined
today by ramsay personality and
best-selling author rachel cruz rachel
we've had a good show so far we have
it's been great it's been fun hosting
with you george you know we have a
special product benefit uh here at
ramsey solutions where each team member
this is pretty cool gets two hundred
dollars i'm gonna call them ramsay bucks
that we can use to get our products at a
discount and i just saw i was so excited
about this my wife probably isn't
listening so i can say this i want to
get her a rachel cruz wallet and it's
finally on there the team has been
waiting product benefits
we get no discount we're not special but
uh i'm so excited because you just
released a new a new flavor if you will
you have
you have the tan the camel that's right
and then we have the black and now a
brand new one yes the classic brown of
the rachel cruz wallet which inside has
the envelopes for your cash to do the
envelope system
it has great places to put your cards
membership debit cards there's an area
to put your change if you need that
and it's genuine leather brown it's the
classic brown the timeless brown that
all of you have been asking for this is
the one color people are like we do a
brown we do a brown um so yeah so we're
going to 50 years this color will still
be in that's right you can count on that
so we released it uh earlier this week
it'll ship
beginning of november first week of
november so if you want it for the
holidays make sure you buy it it's a
great gift um to help people get on
track and to to work the plan but it's
but it's beautiful make your budget
beautiful you know what i'm gonna get
one for my mom too because i just
realized she has the old school rachel
cruz wallet and i think she deserves an
upgrade she does these are yes but these
are beautiful they're made by our
friends that join yeah beautiful
organization doing incredible work
they're fabulous yep they're wonderful
well mama campbell she's probably
listening she listens to every show
she does it's so cute she'll text me
during the breaks
comment on my wardrobe and how i'm doing
it's great
great to have a fan out there so mom if
you're listening uh
you're amazing what would she make us
when we when we go over baklava she
would make oh homemade baklava and give
it to the team oh it was so good man i
missed those days of truck we would
travel remember those days we would do
it we would be gone i feel like all the
time traveling to cities doing
events hanging out with seven city like
money and marriage tours and we do smart
conference and smart money and i hope we
get back to that 2022 we're looking for
you can you believe it's almost 2022 no
it hurts my brain 2021 it still feels
like 20 20. like i feel like 20 21
didn't happen remember like the year
2000 like we were we were basically kids
and we were like it's gonna be 20 22 one
year and now it is we're getting old i
know man it's been a long it's been a
lot well uh open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
laura joins us in miami florida laura
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you i'm so excited to talk to you
both um and speaking of getting older
that uh ties into my question perfect
what a segway
right
i'm in my early 50s i started saving for
retirement a little late about 10 years
ago and i recently left a job where i
was contributing 18
plus a 5 match and then i had my roth on
the side that i was contributing to to
follow my passion which i did and i love
but now i work
for the state
and i can only contribute three percent
to my retirement now there's a choice
between a pension and a self-directed
but i've listened to dave long enough to
know to do the self-directed but they
won't let me contribute any more than
three percent so i do have my rock but
that doesn't quite get me up to my
fifteen percent so i'm wondering is
there any other um tax benefit type
thing where i can put some some more
money for my retirement i wanna dig into
this three percent max i i haven't seen
that where they max you out at three
percent contributions
yeah i called them and they said it's a
florida statute and i said but how are
people supposed to retire on three
percent well that's the statute and i
think they kind of want to push you
towards the tension huh this is very
important
yeah i want to i want i've never heard
it talked about do a lot of research on
this because i mean the irs laws are
very different i would imagine federal
would trump the state laws um but i
would dig into it and you can reach out
have you do you have a good financial
advisor in your corner
i do
okay i want to make sure you have that
we obviously have them smartvestor pros
all around the country but i want them
to dig into this to look into the
options because in your 50s you there
are some great ways to catch up so the
irs lets you contribute more than the
normal amount as you enter your 50s and
head towards retirement but i don't
understand why a
state employer would want their
employees to be broke
i know it's crazy so you said you got
the three percent
three percent into this 401k is that
what it is and they give me a three
percent match
okay
and then on top of that you said you're
maxing out your roth ira yes and then we
also have a non-retirement mutual fund
so i'm wondering if i should just put
extra into that yeah that would be the
next place to go if you've maxed out all
of your retirement kind of tax sheltered
investment vehicles you can go into
taxable investments in just a brokerage
account
which will be obviously taxed at
whatever your income tax rate is but i
want you to dig into this i don't like
this idea i mean if i'm you and you've
still got a decade to work i'm switching
employers if it means i can't contribute
more than three percent laura how much
um how much do you make is it an income
issue because you make a certain amount
or is it just is it just a thing
took a pay cut so
um no it's not that i'm no i they always
tell me it's just it's a florida statute
that's the re that's what i get and when
i look it up i see that too but i've
never heard it talked about on the show
so i
i had to call in
yeah no i'm glad you did well i i would
suggest for sure
um
getting that financial advisor or one of
our smart investor pros to dig in
because they're going to know because i
mean state to state there are things
that differ for sure so they're going to
know specifically what's going on for
you in your area and to give you other
options and so you know there's things
like a back door roth for when you reach
a certain income and there's there's
other variations here again to get that
tax sheltered plans which i think is key
especially for your age but if not
then yes anything anything in a good
just growth stock mutual fund would be
another great place to put it that
because it just has good long one with a
good long track record um
and and what the market's doing now you
know it's it's doing well yeah thanks
for the call all right i'll pulling for
you here i don't know what's going on in
florida this is crazy i'm trying to
google it over here i'm all kinds of
confused
but definitely look into that with your
financial advisor see what your options
are because i want you to be able to
retire with dignity gina joins us in
nashville tennessee gina welcome to the
ramsay show
hi uh
uh george and rachel how are you today
doing great how are you
oh good thanks uh so i'm employed right
now and i want to take out about twenty
thousand dollars out of my 401k
to pay off about two thousand dollars in
federal back taxes and have an emergency
fund
because
i haven't been keeping the job very well
um ever since we moved
out to this area from california last
year
and i'm also working on paying down my
student debt so i wanted to know if you
think that this is a bad idea
for me to hit it this way
yeah if i had a giant buzzer on this
desk that could go ah i would hit it
right now but i don't so i'll just make
the mouth noise gina this it's a bad
move and i'm glad you called before you
make this move we never ever advise
anyone to pull money from the 401k
because you're unplugging all of the
hard work that you've put into it that
compound interest is doing for you and
there's another way to do this you can
clean up this mess and get this
emergency fund in place with your income
that you have so what is your household
income
uh well right now it's pretty much my
husband's and it's about thirty thousand
a year
uh we we literally have no money
and uh and this this these back taxes
federal back taxes over my head i i need
to get them clear and cleaned up so
would you consider taking out a lesser
amount like 5 000 or so i mean i'm
willing to take the hit i'm 60. um so
you know i don't mind just incurring it
in the taxes as income just to get this
off my back and how much is the ira how
much is that again did you say
it's around 2 000.
tina you can do this you uh go drive
uber eats work work i mean do anything
you can to make money do not take money
out of that 401k it's two thousand
dollars you can do it but it does need
to be the very first thing whenever you
have irs debt that's the very first
thing you pay off but gina you guys can
do this you need to get this income up
and and it is possible people are hiring
everywhere right now there's a shortage
of labor so go
follow your pride get any job you can
and get yourself in a good financial
situation
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
jeremiah 29 11. for i know the plans i
have for you declares the lord plans to
prosper you and not to harm you plans to
give you hope and a future
lily tomlin said the road to success is
always under construction that's a good
one
i like that rachel cruz joins me this
hour i'm george campbell this is the
ramsey show and we are taking your calls
ann joins us in new york city and
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you how are you both doing doing
great how can we help
um i called you guys because i just
wanted to know
um i'm a little confused whether um i
should buy a car
with cash or
using a car loan where where's the
confusion coming from
so uh the confusion is because of the
covet situation and everything my
husband had lost his job
and till uh
for like at least 10 years we managed to
ride with one car but now the new job
that he got is going to be requiring to
travel to his workplace
which is going to be it doesn't need to
be
right now but in the coming months maybe
in the next two three months so we were
trying to buy a car but
just confused what to do how much is
this car going to cost
um
the one that i have right now is an old
one so we were trying to buy a new one
just because
yes just because uh the one that i have
is kind of like on its left leg um
how much do you have in savings anne
um right now hundred thousand a hundred
thousand in savings that's great okay do
you have any debt
except for mortgage nothing amazing and
wow you guys have done really well we
got a real easy answer for you and are
you ready
um yeah
pay with cash
and i would say that whether you have a
hundred thousand dollars or a thousand
dollars
um that's what i wanted to do but just
the confusion part came up because of
the
previous situations we had where the job
was lost and everything yes which i
understand absolutely so you're saying
hey i want to keep liquid cash in case
something happens
right right ah but you guys have plenty
of money i mean what does three to six
months of expenses for you guys add up
to
um
with the mortgage and everything it
would come up to i would say uh
like 30 000. okay so that means you have
70 000 to play with here uh and the
other side you said brand new card i
don't like that uh because we don't
recommend you get a brand new car unless
you're a millionaire where you can take
the hit on depreciation are you guys
millionaires
uh no
okay
so if i'm you i'm gonna go look for
maybe a a three three-year-old car
four-year-old car in that same uh range
i mean you guys kind of still afford a
good car what's your household income
the
household income right now with the new
job everything is going to be almost
nine thousand
nine thousand a month
okay that's great yeah and you're in a
great position i mean you just yeah i
mean you think about it the car it's to
get you to point a to point b a great
used car we'll do that totally fine you
have a good amount of money you guys can
get you don't have to get a 5 000 car i
mean you can you can spend a little bit
there and and get a new car for you and
even look to look at and i want you to
spend all 70 000
on two cars by any means but you have
enough to cash flow because here's what
here's where i would go in in your mind
i understand the the mindset okay i
could take out a loan and have more cash
available in case something happens but
here's the deal if something happens
like a job loss again
you're gonna have a car payment and if
you go get two new cars i mean the
average car payment's around 556 six
dollars a month on a new car so if you
guys just theoretically went out and got
two brand new cars you have a thousand
dollars yeah i know you wouldn't but
just go there you're at a thousand
dollar cars a payment for cars with no
income and then you're having to dip
into the emergency fund anyways that
that fund to go and pay off debt so when
you don't have debt you have no bills
you have no risk so
if you go and use some of this money to
go and buy a new car or two new cars and
buy a new car new car to you used um but
something and if something happens with
the job you have no bills and you have
six months worth of an emergency fund in
the bank does that make sense like that
should all give you more peace of mind
than having
a car payments
which ups the risk yeah but it's a great
question anne especially if you're new
to this but we we will never recommend
again even if you have a thousand
dollars in the bank we're not going to
recommend taking out a car loan because
also when you look at just the math too
and for me
you know other debt people um
they justify whether it's like student
loans well you know i'm i'm investing in
myself like right like you hear all
these things but for a car loan it is so
hard for me just mathematically when
people take out a car loan because i'm
like you are taking out a loan you are
paying interest
on an asset that is going down in value
and so by the end of the car loan the
car is worth less than half of what you
bought it and you paid i think on
average i think it's close to eight yeah
eight or nine thousand dollars on top of
what the original was so like just the
math of it i want you to look at it it
should just kind of make you go well
like you'd rather just pay for it be
done
and there's something about it i have
some friends and they've they've always
they've always just done car loans
they've always had you know that's what
they've done and they had to get a new
suv and she was like so we're gonna
we're gonna just pay for it and i was
like that's great you should just pay
pay cash and so a few months ago we were
talking about and she was like i can't
tell you how good it feels
to
just have no payments on a car she's
like i mean it's unbelievable she's like
i never would have thought it would have
felt that great because they always had
the money to pay for a car she was just
like she had the money but they just
chose to get a car but there is
something about at the end of the month
you're not paying to something sitting
here like it's done it is done and you
get to look in the windshield versus the
rear view mirror with your money and
with that new car situation everyone's
always like well it's a new car it's
just way safer i'm like well when you
drive it off the lot it's a used car and
it's just as safe so let's i mean yeah a
three-year-old car is going to do just
fine i have an 09 and i've had no
problems yes very old and i'll tell you
i'm like you know especially those of
you on baby step 2 we and we we take
this call a lot on the show of having to
replace the car because there's a truth
that yeah if you have you know we call
it a hooptie around here but you have a
car and it keeps breaking and the you
know there is a there is a point that
you're spending more on the repairs than
what it's worth like there is a point
yes you need a new car um a new car to
you but i'm like you can go on you can
go on craigslist right now i mean you
can do anything and you can get a great
five six thousand dollar car oh yeah you
don't have that my car was six grand yes
i'm very happy with it still drive it
today yes i mean and even less than that
you can do but i'm like there are there
are great options out there and cars
it is that thing it takes you to point a
to point b but we've gotten in this
thing of like we just love cars in our
country we love we love it and that
they're not bad
uh new cars aren't bad but you just want
to be in a financial situation where you
can take a hit let's take one quick one
here from david david let's get right to
it what's your question
hey y'all it's privilege uh i'm
wondering about rolling over
an old 401k to
to start a roth and
right now my wife and i have life
insurance through primerica
and we've been talking with them about
opening a roth with them is that a whole
life policy
it's term okay cool
yep um
and just you know stuff i've seen
digging it's back and forth like
primerica is an mlm or
you know they say they have no
management fee they just have an upfront
fee
um
you know on paper i don't know when i
talk to them it makes sense but i'm just
kind of unsure if i should invest with
that kind of company or if i should do
my own thing through vanguard or
you know maybe i'll say a smart buster
with ramsey
just kind of where to start to open a
roth
yeah it's a great question yeah i mean
for sure my first step was just sit down
with the smart fester pro and they're
someone that we just recommend they
don't work for us but they are
investment professionals in areas all
over the country that that follow the
baby steps follow what we do because
here's the here's the the rub always
when it comes to
insurance investing all of those you
never want them so close right i know
that's not a wholesale or i'm sorry a
whole life policy but
to have those to have those separate and
i would just i would get a second third
opinion for sure and and talk to smart
investor pro because there's able if
you're able to pay the taxes you'll be
able to roll some of that over to either
a traditional ira but if you pay the
taxes then the roth is great um to do
but you do want someone i think in your
corner to help because there's a lot of
intricacies when it comes
i took one yesterday financial advisor
was trying to get him to switch from
term to whole life and i was like oh
well does he sell whole life the answer
was yes and i was like get dude drop him
drop him now yeah good question david
definitely connect with the smart
investor pro ramsay ramseysolutions.com
and they can help you do things the
right way that's what i did when i
rolled over an old 401k and they set me
up real nice and helped me understand
what i was doing that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books my thanks
to ben hill operating the board kelly
daniel rachel cruz my co-host and you
america it's been a fun show thank you
for listening we'll be back with you
before you know it this is the ramsey
show this is james childs producer of
the ramsey show you can listen to all
our shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you